The joe rogan experience.
Um,
so,
uh,
you and you were married at the time and you were getting divorced while we were
doing the show.
And,
uh,
it was one of the craziest things I've ever seen in my life and not just to Phil
Hartman divorce thing,
you know,
scared me.
But Dave thinks carried me.
And one of the reasons why Dave scenes things scared me was you do not want to
get fucking married in Canada because when you break up in Canada,
say you decide you want to get a divorce,
you can't legally get divorced until you're separate for a year,
right?
That's correct.
I'm not sure.
I can't even remember.
I believe it was a year.
It's tattooed in my brain because I remember thinking how crazy this was that
you were fucked.
And what was happening was his wife,
his first wife,
uh,
was,
at Accenture character and she decided to start taking this shit all over the
fucking world,
or a content on the radio.
I would have gone with that.
But you know,
you're a great guy and I want to say,
yeah,
well she's the mother of your children.
So yeah,
that doesn't excuse that.
Does that is not a get out of get out of countries.
Well,
uh,
she was very odd and uh,
the,
the first season the guys were together and then I believe by the second season
it was over.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It,
we split up.
And so she started,
what she would do is spend all days money.
So Dave would be working and she would spend all day,
it's money,
I mean by crazy expensive furniture fly all around the world all the time.
So whenever Dave wanted to see his kids,
he used to have to get fucking malaria shots.
Yeah.
Okay.
So one time we were at one of these NBC things and Dave's fucked up on malaria
medication and gin and tonics or whatever the fuck you were drinking.
Yeah.
And you get like,
like crazy.
I had to stop Dave from beating a guy up.
I had to step in between.
Do you remember the big guy with the long hair with the fucking dawn Jovi's
Tony.
Yeah,
Tony Carry.
It wasn't,
it wasn't that the guy had done anything wrong.
It was just the malaria medication.
You become a psychotic,
it's a very common uh,
effect.
Especially apparently when you mix it with alcohol.
Yeah.
Well,
and you,
and then you added that having made two trips to Africa.
Yeah.
Month.
Yes.
Africa to see his fucking kids.
Like I had to fly to,
I had to fly to Morocco at Thanksgiving and so we had two weeks off of it.
So I had floated,
flew to uh,
and this again.
And she,
when we first separated,
she took the kids,
we just said we'd like a summer sent mom divorce where it was like I need to
take the children to the continent and gather my thoughts.
So she like traveled through Europe with,
you know,
a six month old baby and a two year,
two and a half year old for six months.
And then,
so then Thanksgiving there and Morocco.
So I had to go meet him in Morocco.
So I get to spend 10 days in Morocco,
then another 24 hours flying back.
And then two weeks later we get our Christmas break.
So I have to fly to Zimbabwe and there was nothing you could've done like taking
your money and you're like,
Hey,
I'm giving it to Joe or something like that.
No,
it was like a old money.
Yeah,
no have to,
you're responsible for taking care of their wellbeing at the time when I like
when I made her get into therapy,
she's,
uh,
like I forced her to get us to get into couple's therapy
cause I was miserable.
Um,
and,
and so since we got,
I'd say,
let's go to therapy.
She said,
well,
I've got to go first.
All right,
you can go see the therapist at the traffic.
Yeah.
So she goes in and explains to the therapist that I'm an abusive husband,
uh,
you know,
and then she starts pulling any,
excuse me,
being physically abusive.
Uh,
and then she starts like phoning my family and friends and saying that
physically abusive or complete fabrications.
Right.
So she's just creating stories.
A good friend of mine,
Steve,
when he heard this said,
that's crazy.
If,
if Dave was abusive,
she would be dead.
You know,
but no,
but then I go into therapy and the therapist goes,
you know,
who is prepared for this abusive husband and to walk in.
And she goes,
it was,
and she explained to me later,
she said it was very weird because you walked in and you didn't match the
description of you at all.
And it's just said when you walked in yet.
And I saw you two together,
I immediately realized that if anyone in this couple was abused,
it was,
it was me.
Did the therapist say this to her?
Uh,
I don't know if she ever said it to her in therapy.
Did you have a one on one with the third?
I have one on one with it.
We have,
we both saw her individually and together.
And then after,
uh,
about six months of therapy,
my wife,
uh,
when I thought things were starting to get better cause I was,
I was able to do things like go CD shopping with Steve,
uh,
without getting,
without that being a huge fight when I got home,
you know,
so that was like,
I thought,
oh,
I'm a little bit of freedom here.
I can go out and hang out with,
hang out with my friends for a little bit without there being a huge fight.
And uh,
but then she was diagnosed as having borderline personality disorder by our
therapy.
That exactly mean why is it borderline personality disorder?
It's a misnomer.
Really don't like it.
They used to,
they used to think it was because it was a condition that bordered on being
psychotic.
Um,
and now it's,
they,
they know that isn't the condition.
It's not anything to do with psychosis.
But the name has stuck.
The problem with my problem with the name is when you say borderline personality
disorder,
do you have a fucking personality disorder or not?
What is borderline?
You're kind of weird kind of.
Cause in fact borderline's a lot of therapists when even treat them cause they,
they think they're just impossible to treat and that they're horrible people to
deal with.
You know that they're incredibly dishonest.
The pathological liars.
How do you define it though?
How can you define certain sets of mental illness?
I mean who was it a judgment call?
There's like a,
was the Dsm,
is that what it's called?
The diagnostic standards manual or something like that.
And it's got like a checklist and if you score a certain number on the
checklist,
they go,
that's a diagnosis.
And I think,
uh,
she had like nine at a 10 on the checklist for borderline.
Was she always this way or did she change?
She was always that way.
Yeah.
Like basically as soon as we became a couple,
like before we were a couple,
she was like my,
um,
before she did,
she was my best friend's girlfriend.
Oh Shit.
You know,
it's Karma son.
Yeah.
That's what happened.
You know,
you got hooked up with Karma.
It was like one of these things where it's like,
did she break up with him first and then go out with you or you can,
no,
no.
It was like one of these things where I sort of said,
look,
I,
you know,
we should stop hanging out so much cause I'm,
I was like feeling bad about it.
I was like 20 years old and at that point kind of lonely and desperate and said,
look,
I've got these feelings and we should stop hanging out together alone.
Really?
You actually said I have these feelings and we should stop hanging out.
Yeah.
How many guys will do that?
Very few.
Yeah.
And her,
her reaction to that was the,
the uh,
she just showed me her tits and started kissing me.
So it was like,
oh,
all right,
all I tried,
you did give it your best.
So,
um,
so what happens then you go to the buddy and go,
hey bro,
fuck your girlfriend.
Hey.
Yeah.
Well,
I tried to cool it,
tried to get out of it and I even was out of town for a while and tried to stay
away from it.
But um,
you know,
he was probably like thank God,
thank God.
Yeah.
Well that's the thing is I didn't realize at the time cause I gotten gone all
right.
I thought things were okay with them and uh,
and I,
you know,
and it wasn't til she and I hooked up like,
cause again,
as soon as we hook cause borderlines when they love you,
you're the most beautiful,
perfect thing in the world.
But then,
uh,
but then after that,
like if anything is wrong,
then you suddenly become the most evil,
dark,
horrible thing in the world and they can't,
they can't see the two at the same time,
they can't see your flaws and your,
and your virtues.
How do the same time,
wow.
I think I've dated somebody.
Every girl you remember that you'd like,
man,
I need to write this fucking guy.
You don't even know.
He just got out of a relationship with a penthouse pet of the year.
Oh real it,
it was wonderful for me.
It was like I had my own soap opera going on,
but it was also just like this where,
where,
when Shit went down,
it was,
it was on or off.
It was no like,
oh,
shits down.
Maybe we can work through this.
It was just,
that's one of the key signals of a borderline,
uh,
is that,
that in the,
they say it's the inability to recognize the good and bad and the same person,
you know,
you can shift from being the most evil person to the greatest person.
I 100%.
Yeah.
So with my first wife before we were a couple,
when it was just,
you know,
uh,
elicit,
you know,
when it was like this secret feelings,
uh,
you know,
a movie,
we're friends,
I was the greatest guy he was,
and she made me feel like I was the greatest guy on earth.
So you thought this is the perfect woman for me,
even know she's with my friend.
You know,
they do.
Yeah.
And then,
but as soon as we became a couple first thing that like sex gone immediately and
we didn't have sex for 11 years.
We were together for 11 years and we'd have sex maybe once a year.
Oh my God.
How did you two kids?
Uh,
once a year.
Really I have very motel sperm.
Um,
Holy Shit.
We had kids cause she decided she wanted to get pregnant and,
and even at that point that,
oh well at least we'll get laid,
you know.
And uh,
what were your friends while this was all going on?
Well,
what men friends always do.
It depends on the men friends.
They never say anything.
They just sit there and quietly eight and hate her,
not me,
man.
Yeah.
I've learned from the Phil Hartman experience,
I tell people.
Yeah.
And whenever I think that my friends in a bad situation,
I,
I'll,
I will pull them aside.
I've,
I've offered,
which is on risk.
You should take for a friend.
Yeah.
I've had friends stay at my house.
Dunkin stayed at my house for a few months after he got out.
You know,
you've got to tell people like,
Bro,
this is,
you're stuck and you think for some reason or that this person is a part of your
life,
they are not,
this is,
this is a show that you're tuning into that you should shut off.
Yeah.
Okay.
For me,
it was like this,
a lot of guilt about how we started course.
And then eventually,
eventually,
you know,
I'm gonna,
I'm almost as crazy as she is after 11 years of no fucking,
your brain doesn't function properly,
you know,
and it's also 11 years of like twice a month,
suicide threats,
you know,
uh,
and then,
you know,
then I,
I got to the point where I was so crazy,
I thought,
well,
hey,
at least if we have a kid,
you know,
if we have a kid,
she won't kill herself when I leave.
You know?
And that's how crazy.
And literally,
within less than a month after my son was born,
uh,
out of nowhere,
she goes,
you know,
I've been thinking about it.
And I think if you left me,
even with a baby,
I would still kill myself.
I was like,
she could read my mind.
Whoa.
I've been thinking about it.
Holy Shit.
And was like,
Oh really?
I have a look.
At that time I was like,
when tabs and I split up,
she was going through about 50 grand a month.
Damn it's,
and that was before we had it.
That was before we had like a separation agreement.
Half a million a year.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Running,
spending it.
And you have to make a million to spend a half a million.
Yeah.
She's been so fun.
She was renovating the house constantly to be heard,
to be heard and that she rescate re lance had the backyard re landscape twice
cause she decided she didn't like where the Koi pond was.
Oh my God.
You know that's like,
you know,
core core ponds are pretty awesome though.
Yeah.
That's one thing I've always thought about killing whenever we get around to
lead.
That's nice.
You know,
like you can't really raise a child in a healthy home without a collective.
That was at our argument,
our argument.
And he was all for the kids.
Yeah.
The kids need a Koi pond.
Kids need to go to Morocco.
Yeah,
worry about getting bitten by a poisonous insects to turn like the third.
She kept renovate this house,
like at least spent like another,
like a half a million dollars renovating a fully renovated house.
Well this is why I brought this up.
So I ran into you on Twitter.
I saw you on Twitter and one of the first things I saw you on Twitter was you
talking about how you had just gotten,
uh,
the,
the court had just told you you have to pay three times your monthly salary in
alimony.
And again,
it's two times slept,
but I would say as an average because a lot of months I don't have a salary.
Uh,
no.
I,
yeah,
they ordered,
uh,
I had to pay $17,700 a month or go to jail for 10 days every month that I'm late
without warning.
That's,
that was the 10th the judge's ruling jail for 10 days.
So do you have to bit be exported to Canada?
Is that what it,
well,
that's the thing.
I'm here,
so,
so do you know,
say fuck you,
I live here now and just stay here,
but I,
yeah,
I can't risk going back to Canada.
You go to jail.
Yeah.
Whoa.
So unless I've come up with 17,000,
$700,
which in a month where I haven't earned anything is a little hard to do that.
So how much are you sending over there?
Are you trying to like whatever?
Like I sent five grand this past month and this should go crazy.
It's 20 grand in November.
Did she go crazy and yell at you like you need more?
And I need that.
She hasn't talked to me directly,
you know,
really it's all through lawyers.
But again,
they were trying,
uh,
through this organization called the fro the family responsibility office in
Ontario that,
and this,
this legal office is really responsible for hounding a lot of men to their
death.
Like there's a real problem with like people committing suicide,
um,
after being prosecuted by these people.
And,
uh,
they,
they were trying to get me like in November,
I've sitting in a court in like November 20th,
I guess,
sitting in court and thinking at the end of that day,
I might go to jail for six months.
They were,
they were pushing for me to go to jail for six months.
This is what the fro is asking,
six month jail sentence.
If I didn't come up with half $1 million that day,
um,
and an additional 30 days for every month,
I didn't come up with the money.
Oh my God.
So,
and I was sitting there going,
well,
the judge,
if he goes for it,
I in jail for life,
they'll cuff me there that day to God.
And I'll go to jail for six months.
The end of six months,
they'll say,
you know,
well,
do you have the half million dollars?
And plus the ongoing money that would accrue over the six months.
And I'd say,
no,
I've been in jail for six months.
How was I supposed to earn any money?
All right,
that's another 30 days.
The end of that 30 days you got the money.
No,
I been in jail.
So it's essentially a life sentence.
Unless someone gives you $500,000.
Yeah.
How long?
How long,
how much longer do you have for this?
Uh,
well,
it's really,
it's,
I'm ending until I pay off the arrears,
that io or,
you know,
and that's crazy.
And then until the kids are,
uh,
22 if they stay in school,
so,
and the skin and so then the money just keeps adding up.
And you know,
my Dick off tonight?
Yeah.
Like,
I mean,
don't,
you know,
just don't marry Canadian shirk.
Yeah.
I mean,
in order to pay $17,700,
I have to earn about $40,000 in a month just to pay that.
Just,
you know,
with,
20% commission,
35% tax bracket,
um,
you know,
so I've got to earn 40,000 just to have $0 million.
Fuck.
And it's just,
it's so close to someone you hate.
Yeah.
And he didn't fuck me for 11 years.
Tell called crazy ass laws.
And then when you tell them that you don't make that much money anymore,
what do they say to the judge pat who made this ruling because they were,
I asked you for this six months.
Right?
And the judge kept saying to the fro attorney,
uh,
you know,
give me another option because I'm looking at,
I'm looking at the,
the,
the financial documents and I'm seeing where all the money,
all the money that has come in and I'm seeing where it's all gone.
It's all here in this documents,
all the money that's come in and where it's all gone.
I can see it all in these documents.
So I am convinced that there isn't a half a million dollars from Mr. Foley to
come up with today.
So if you insist on that ruling,
then I would send them to jail and your client will never see another dime
because Mister Foley's career will be over.
And that's it.
And he kept saying,
give me an option that will get your client some money and the Fr or refused.
They said,
well,
we don't have the authority from our client,
my ex wife,
to make any other offer.
Um,
so for about two hours,
the judge kept asking them to come up with another.
So all this time while you're sitting there,
you're going,
I'm going to jail.
Yeah.
And I might be going to jail essentially forever.
What happened?
Going to jail for being for the crime of not earning $1 million.
Oh my God.
So what happens if that actually does happen?
I mean,
we have guys gone in jail with a large sum like that and never come out.
I don't know.
But people have definitely gone to jail and,
and definitely there's a lot of people who have been looking at jail time who
have just killed themselves.
Uh,
you know,
can,
can you get the kids and then have him stay with you so that she has the towel?
Vone bro.
It's alimony.
Well,
there's no,
this is child support.
It's all child support.
This is all child support.
The kids thousand a month in child support.
Yeah.
Steal the kids.
What the fuck are your kids eating?
A $17,000 iPhone or eating I iPhones.
Yeah.
It's incredible.
17 $17,700 a month.
That's crazy.
Block.
Yeah.
I would,
I would talk to the kid and be like,
Hey,
come live with me.
We'll have a TV show together.
I'll get you a podcast and somehow turn the tables.
Well,
yeah,
I mean get a horse.
Yeah.
A couple of quotes thought about being on the real house,
husbands of Beverly Hills,
but I'm thinking we can get a reality show off the ground.
What do you,
are you willing to marry a Kardashians?
Uh,
Oh my God,
I've,
well,
hey,
I can't marry worse than I have because they'd probably be a lot better.
Yeah.
Crazy.
They're just an ambitious man.
Fuck man.
So what's the solution?
So you cannot to Canada and you
just send whatever you have and then you have to constantly deal with legal
payments because they're constantly trying to fuck you.
And she spent like year and a half
literally going to court every single month with lawyers.
Just basically having to go to court every month,
just,
just stay out of jail to go and have them put it over till the next month.
And the lawyers,
the lawyers,
you know,
I mean the people that do family law,
a lot of them are really horrible people and they just make money off misery.
And even my own words,
we're just extending this as far as they could until I ran out of money and
like,
and then quit.
So when I went to court for this ruling,
I didn't have,
I didn't have a lawyer that couldn't afford one.
So you went by yourself,
was there by myself.
Not only was that there by myself,
but all of the documents that had been piled up,
all of the evidence that had been piled up over the course of a year and a half
was sitting in my lawyer's office.
Oh my God.
You know.
So you had no evidence and no lawyer.
Yeah.
Did you have records?
Did you have anything?
Nothing.
I had nothing.
God.
So you're just going from there.
Nothing.
I have no money.
I,
this is all I can do.
Yeah.
And they're asking me questions about files that have been piling up over a year
and a half.
You know,
I don't know.
I don't recall.
I don't,
you know,
cause I don't,
how do they justify such an exorbitant amount of money?
Uh,
because it's the,
the,
as it was explained to me by my lawyers was that the courts,
uh,
assumption is that the children should continue to live at the level they were
at,
at the time of the dissolution of the marriage.
So,
which is crazy because if I were still married and my income dropped,
their lifestyle would change.
Right.
But because we're not married anymore,
their lifestyle should never change no matter what I'm earning.
What's that?
The judge,
the ruling that was enforced was by another judge named judge justice back
backhouse.
And she's the one who ruled about three,
four years ago when I went back to try and get it adjusted,
I went to,
um,
to,
uh,
have to have a hearing to have it adjusted to meet my income.
Um,
and she ruled against me and in her ruling she said my ability to pay was not
relevant to my obligation.
So it didn't matter to her what I proved my income to be if my income was zero,
she said I was still obligated to pay as though I was earning $1 million.
I know a lot of people were saying,
Joe Rogan this day,
fully guys bombing me the fuck out.
Like,
well listen,
this is some important shit.
This was my education in,
in relationships and the law regarding relationships as I was growing up.
But literally,
I mean,
when I was on news radio was a fresh face boy didn't know Jack Shit about the
world.
And this is how I learned about relationships and just how I learned about all
the whole gamut from divorce to fucking murder suicide.
And I learned it all.
You are happily married.
Yeah.
Crazy.
What are you guys figured it out?
Who Know?
Got Lucky.
Could go ugly for me too.
Wish I could do on your podcast.
I would probably seriously just move somewhere like live on a beach in Jimmy
loves his kids.
You get to see your kids.
Not now.
I can't go to Canada so they can't see.
So you don't see him at all?
No.
It was the last time you saw them?
Uh,
was in uh,
uh,
November.
Wow.
That would drive me nuts.
That's my size.
Went to see my,
my son's play at school.
It was last time I saw him.
And was the check there,
the wife?
No,
no,
she wasn't there.
Thank God.
So you have no communication with her at all?
No,
no,
not,
you don't have to pay any more alimony.
No,
she didn't seek alimony.
She sought a child support cause yeah.
But none of it got to the kids,
you know,
it all goes to her.
Yeah.
She was getting,
you know,
all this money.
And then on top of the child support payment,
which is,
she was also getting something called section seven expenses.
But just basically anything she chose to,
to any bills she chose to run up,
what,
you know,
so it'd be like $20,000 for summer camp,
things like that.
Anything that was for the kids that she chose.
Yeah.
So not just alimony,
not we're not just child support,
but child support plus and then all of her living expenses,
you know,
like the Mar,
the mortgage,
and you know,
everything,
medical expenses,
everything.
It just makes me so it's,
it should make you sick.
Ah.